[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants bonsoir pas trop je
sens qu'aujourd'hui je vais
confectionner quelque chose de
succulents quad en ours une tarte aux
cerises
j'ai une recette extraordinaire je vous
en rapporterait un morceau et vous m'en
direz des nouvelles on les jeunes les
pop pop ont beau
pot 6 ans caché sous la table nicolas
hall ou non nous on ne se cache pas ce
soir on fait de la cuisine
d'un appentis bonne chose note un panier
des cerises
chekkal ya vite dans la cuisine grand
chef
[Musique]
nathan chapeau d'abord et donc pas les
cerises
je les pose sur la table
son père j'ai acheté les plus rouge que
j'ai trouvé
elles ont l'air bas descola ne touche
pas les cerises nous allons faire une
tarte
hoyaux
il me faut un moule à ta
voix la grand chef cuisinier tu veux le
faire cuire 10 cbl ce triste bien sûr
puisque nous allons faire une temps lana
quel dommage
on m'a frappé non non c'est sûrement
pour toi ça on est toujours dérangé
quand il le groupe
qui est là
[Musique]
dia personnes
elles sont famille d'armida cette étude
erreur bon mon moule à tarte
la du sucre
[Musique]
cette fois moore sont à frapper vraiment
à oui je vais voir ne touchez à rien
alors il ya quelqu'un où il n'y a
personne
je me demande si ce n'est pas une farce
les chenapans
où les vient le malappris ils ont mangé
toutes des cerises tout toutes les
grosses tout les petits on lit ou lycéen
en annonce de grands chefs cuisiniers
aucune voix non je ne vous dis pas au
revoir vous êtes des petits coquins ou
les
hémois qui avait promis un morceau de
tarte à mon patron
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors grand cuisinier et cet art je suis
fâché pas trop fâché ils m'ont manger
toute méprise je n'ai pas pu faire
doctor who ça ne fait rien ne nous
nicolas et pimprenelle on manger des
cerises parce qu'elle était très bonne
et très belle oui mais moi je n'aurais
pas beau jeu et vous vous ne veut pas la
porte bonne nuit des enfants allez vite
vous coucher le fuck de boer vous
[Musique]
oh